[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
ну
[музыка]
мы будем передвигаться с точки а в точку
б как бы крутой не был сергей он за все
отвечать не может потому что это река
пороге комары гнулся еще чуток всякому
по пути произойти поэтому вы должны
управлять своими ожиданиями и не
понимаете мир
реальность она какая есть такая есть она
и не плохая и не хорошая все зависит от
ваших ожиданий если у вас завышенные
ожидания то мир для вас кажется злой и
не хороший если у вас заниженные
ожидания там нет для вас полный сюрприз
энгри так далее интересен огромное
внимание уделяйте безопасность потому
что если с вами с любым из вас что-то
случится то все пойдет насмарку
настроение упадет у всех там и победа
проведем инструктаж упакуем ровд и
своими личными вещами снаряжением то
есть один раб уже ребята там нас ждут
они сегодня уже уехали уже готовят раб
ты
[аплодисменты]
погода супер тоже очень перемещу пока
ехали уже 2 и 3 раза дочь прокопал я
думаю что этот сплав нас порадует
погодой в разнообразной первый день у
нас по программе так на реке белая оба
мы сейчас находимся после этого не
полкилометра ниже будет слияние черные
белые губы там зарождается большая уба
супер готов уместился в свой рюкзак и
водку шириной в предвкушении да и очень
интересных восточный казахстан крафтинг
мы готовы готова готовы
спецназа девается
смотрите чтобы было удобно грести ложим
весло на голову должен быть угол 90
градусов это оптимально для грех
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
только потом
да мы сначала вверх потом вниз потом
плохо
промокли до не так еле вылез оттуда из
этой дыры на скрутила верхнего крутила
вертепа раз она только благодаря
прочтены людьми команды мы вот здесь
ощущение как будто на американских
горках очень круто
[музыка]
c builder
уходит
поклон и расслабиться слова
так
[музыка]
молодец мышцы растут
уходит мышцы раз вы ну если честно
впечатление они выше моих ожиданий
поскольку я даже не мог представить что
мы будем быть получается по такой
красивой природе самое наверное
интересно это мы
когда есть скажем так соперник есть
соперничество
как-то движешься быстрее вот сегодня мы
быть друга йосла не забрасывали водой и
это было интересно
[музыка]
настроение классная сегодня погода такая
замечательная вот вчера было так это
сурово
вот но интересно прошла буквально одна
ночь и уже то что было сурово не
вспоминаешь а думаешь о приключении были
ну что готовы мы сегодня мы готовы как
никогда
[музыка]
мы
даже кайрат не может догнать на своей
ferrari
[музыка]
я думаю как важно человеку выходить на
природу и именно без
повседневных этих телефонов связи
интернет телефон все отвлекается ни
понимать что какие-то вещи в жизни они
волю важнее и жизнь на сказка
[музыка]
до порога с прикольных когда волны
приходишь обливаешься ну интересно
оно того стоит логан единой
[музыка]
сегодня у нас чай а зверобой мужская
трава это малина многие сегодня уже
искупались
во время рафтинга все мокро она от
простуды во ладушка эта трава очень
сильно очистит печень многие лечения
начинают именно с вала дужки что
прочистить печень тем но и городские
жители нам прям маст-хэв
жизни так если там сам создаешь
постоянно проблем дата костра и внешне
проявляются а если ты ничего не делаешь
обязательно внешней проблем придут не
бывает жизни чтобы не проходили проблема
не бывает потому что смогли вот надо
представить что ваш бизнес и так как
тело котором воздухе
если ты перестал себе создать проблемы
то есть махать крыльями
автоматический бизнес начнет падать а
что только падение это конечно проблем
все ты пошел вниз
традицию руси во время махать махать
крыльями и домах открыли мы ценой все
проблемы мульта выйти надо расти еще
поэтому в интенсивнее над махом давайте
простим тоже как жизни через то
спокойная вода к расслабился оба
бусинами дзи впору видели трех бокам
всего проблемы проблемы внешними а когда
ты видишь и начинаешь сам все собрать
проблем игры сгребешь и пошел в
управляемый процесс взгляд проблемы
никуда не деваются ноты управляемого
через них проходишь это в целом в жизни
так и всегда ситуация такая либо ты
управляешь своей жизнью либо жизнь
управлять того яковлев так понял такую
вещь я когда с кем-то бою и по бизнесу
мы с ним движемся не по вдоль реки а
бьемся об друг друга в это время все со
стороны смотрят и дальше проплывают
лучший способ победить на нее не
участвовать в ней
[музыка]
но
сегодня был этот кайфовый рафтинг просто
вот под лежали
[музыка]
на одном дыхании спалось
проснуться возле реки
под поджог кредит хоть бы пороге были
покруче макромир помощнее я и так
побольше да погода обещает быть
непредсказуемой тем интереснее
[музыка]
смысл у механика для игры под названием
жизнь заключается в том что тебе дают
ограниченные ресурсы виде внимания
энергии времени t и говорят а теперь
попробует с этими ресурсами добиться
максимума поэтому вот основные ресурсы
не деньги несвязные знания вот это
основные ресурсы и вот когда многие люди
думают лишних знаний не бывает начинают
все изучать они тратят попусту очень
много времени я наоборот очень много
люди собирают лишних знаний то есть
ценность знаний переоценена
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
удачу сайт тут как дикий чеснок говорит
лишь одно это по-нашему чей сайт вот так
долю он камней растет правда бывает что
мысли всегда постоянно посещает там блин
чё там творится в городе дома там ищут
не ищут а потом начинаешь осознавать что
этот шаг как то без тебя должны люди там
обходиться и ты сам себя наверно
приучаешь к тому чтобы ты находился
самим собой иногда мы уже за два дня
можно сказать приловчитесь уже имеем
какой-то опыт какие-то навыки удачно
переплыли через этот третий сплав но
говорят обещают что 5 спав будет вообще
самые экстремальные
жду-не дождусь
им стал канатов на
вывод
[музыка]
но
конечно
заставлен практику чаши вина где будем
они отвесного берега john baner доход
[музыка]
мусор
что
фигура
зубы тоже чистым кстати здесь в реке
самое главное что туалет находился на
той стороне против сплава иногда люди
ходят на эту сторону
хотя огонь tomoya и парк и отжигает
выходишь горная вода мягкая холодное
бодряще отличный день прекрасная ванне
сакская
прекрасная природа здесь очень круто это
была лучшая баня который я был лучшие
компании лучше вместе
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
ребята собирается прыгнуть горы в реку и
поплыть на предложение
предложение норманны а мы наверное
сегодня будет правителями
[музыка]
только что сплавились дизраптор нажили
это экстрим был супер первый раз
спалились прибило к берегу так
более-менее по спокойному но об камни
пару раз ударились ну легко когда волна
накрывает тебя подряд и скорость вообще
супер еще адреналин сервал латов кровь
бьет и этот чуть-чуть такое сердце вода
холодная было а второй раз я буду правда
не почувствовал даже я больше думал как
бы подняли на ли были середину вот этот
хотелось
это было супер адреналин прям о качает 1
2 это мы на камень заметили и лодка
прямо так почти на пополам это передняя
часть ушла еще на чём не и потом
вот и пошла вам
[музыка]
макеев полежим как партнеры
вот лежит
придется
[музыка]
это гриб боровик самый лучший гриб
в наших лесах он хороший в жареном виде
в сушеном виде классный
[музыка]
бой классное утра вообще проснулись
птички поют река горная шумит запах леса
просто класс встретить не насытились так
все этой природной атмосферой такой
хорошей компании зарядились энергией
реально чувствуешь себя перезагружен
инициирована в 7:05 ну ночью-то храпел
страшно промежуток как медведи на работу
до начала не храпели сильно и раз
подставляет постоянно
[смех]
именно ведь именно в нашей стороне и там
дальше медведей попадусь 15 первый это
когда вы берете одну проблему и пять раз
задаете вопрос почему для того чтобы
докопаться до корневой причины этой
работы я это ещё одно слоя второй метод
это когда ты доходишь до ствола проблема
там тыкаем придумываем до ствола не
бывает
456 проблем если хорошо пройдут подумай
ты поймешь что у них ст владимир
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
самое тяжелое взял на себя и надо
бояться трудностей на самом деле надо
носить столько сколько можешь чтобы
побольше и в длинную таскать тут и
заканчивается наше приключение все
дружно собираемся все стали как одна
большая семья все ребята отличная
организация супер
рафтинг нужно сказать превзошел ожидания
вот
дальше не крайне нет такой спокойно
плывем общаемся уже команда стала как
друзья близкий классно но сейчас пойдем
обратно окунемся в город
будем заниматься своими делами но я
думаю уже мы будем на это смотреть
по-другому для меня польза такая что я
этот очень давно уже так не выходил на
вот такой воздух чтобы 45 не отключить
телефон у меня всегда тревога там что
происходит кто-то не ищи там звонит но я
общался смартфон калечим общались
задавали вопросы
в основном
меня больше беспокоило вот вопросы
семейной там я задал ему как с детьми
общественно то есть до плюс какие-то
рабочие моменты духовные моменты и зла
вчера мой у меня самый большой inside
это то что
надо вот так выходить а отключать
телефон и
приучать себя чтобы ты не волновался за
тех кто сейчас там на другой стороне том
городе до быть полностью отключиться от
этой от этих эмоций и переживаний и
просто наслаждаться природой
[музыка]
возвращение
машину на вашем мой к шуму миру
сообщение много как
я возьму и нужны в этом мире на меня
более тысячи сообщений
если честно ехал связь появилась уже но
я до последнего не открывала капот я
хочу растянуть это удовольствие сегодня
у нас финальный ужин сегодня мы
проставляем
угощаем команду марван калиевич а с
нашим успешный брак скин-кап
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
наши сильные стороны являются нашими
самыми слабыми местами
[музыка]